We are given a table,
which contains the plurality of n,
where n equals 1, 2, 3, 4
and the corresponding values ​​of g of n are given.
One way to look at it is that this function g
defines a row in which n is the number of an array member.
Or it is the same
as a line in which the first article is 168,
the second is 84, the third is 42,
and the fourth member is 21,
as it continues, and more, and more.
Now let's think of what kind of line is that.
Assuming it starts at 168,
how will we go from 168 to 84?
One way is to get 84,
and another way is to multiply by 1/2.
We multiply by 1/2.
And then, to go from 84 to 42,
we multiply again by 1/2.
And to go from 42 to 21, we multiply again by half.
So here's a geometric progression.
We start with a member and each next member
is the previous article multiplied by 1/2,
or as it is often called - in the general private of progression.
How can we write g from n, how can we set the progression
obviously regarding n?
I recommend that you pause the video
and think about how to do it.
So if I say g of n equals ...
let's try to describe the function,
which we just saw here starting at 168,
and then multiply by 1/2 each time,
when adding a new member.
Well, one way is to start with 168
and then multiply by 1/2,
we will multiply by 1/2 a certain number of times.
We can look at the pointer as number of times,
number multiplied by 1/2.
How many times will we multiply by 1/2?
We multiply the first member by 1/2 zero times.
The second one multiplies by one-half once.
We multiply the third member twice by 1/2.
We multiply the fourth article three times by 1/2.
It seems that regardless of which member we are,
we multiply by 1/2 as many times as the member's number minus 1.
You can check that it is.
If n equals 1, you will have
1 minus 1, which will be 0.
1/2 at grade 0 is simply 1.
So you get 168.
If n is 2, 2 minus 1,
you will multiply by 1/2 once,
here is n is 3,
you will multiply twice by 1/2,
because 3 minus 1 is 2.
You will multiply twice by 1/2,
as you see it here.
So it looks like a really nice set of definitions
for this geometric progression.
You can also view it in other ways,
you can write it like g of n equals,
to see, one of the ways to write it is
as 168 and simply algebraic
I process it on 2 in degree n minus 1.
The other way you can view it,
let us use the properties of degrees a little,
we can say that g of n equals to, let's see,
1/2 of n minus 1, this is the same
like 1/2, let me write it down.
This is equal to 168.
Let me write it in another color.
This part here is the same thing
such as 1/2 of degree n.
So we have 1/2 of degree n by 1/2 of grade minus 1.
1/2 degree minus 1,
which is equal to 2, so
this is 2.
So we can write this whole thing like
168 by 2 is how much?
336?
336, did I decide it true?
160 by 2 will be 320, plus 16,
2 at 8, yes, 336.
And then we have 1/2 of grade n.
1/2 degree n.
So these are equivalent statements.
This has a slightly more intuitive meaning,
in a sense, it just pops out, you start with 168
and multiply by 1/2.
By the member you are in, minus 1.
But this is algebraically equivalent to that,
the original one.
But can we also define g of n by giving it recurrently?
Again, I recommend pausing the video and trying to do it.
In many ways, the recurrent definition
it's a little easier, so let's do it.
g, will write the assigned function in a different color,
I will continue with g of n,
as this is used in the table here.
g of n equals to, let's see,
when n equals 1,
if n equals 1, we begin with 168.
If n is greater than 1 and is a natural number,
this will be determined for all positive integer numbers,
what will we do?
We will take 1/2 and multiply it
under the previous article.
So we will have 1/2 per g of n minus 1.
You can check that it is.
If n equals 1, just go right here,
we have 168.
g of 2 will be 1/2 g of 1,
which is of course 168.
So we have 168 by 1/2, that's 84.
g of 3 will be 1/2 g of 2,
or g of 3 is 1/2 g of 2.
Thus, we define:
this is the explicit definition of this geometric progression,
this is the recursive function for setting this geometric progression.